it's the beginning of a new era in
Uruguay
a center-right Oaxaca Depot was sworn in
as president on Sunday for 15 years the
center-left ruled a small South American
nation turning it into the most
progressive in the region by legalizing
marijuana abortion and same-sex marriage
but the new president says it's time for
change the citizens gave a strong
message to me the people spoke that it
is necessary to change but a change with
consensus it's now time to fulfill
people's will present at his
inauguration were right-wing leaders
from the region like Brazil's jair
volson ro and Chile Sebastian Pinera
Venezuelans who came to Uruguay because
of the crisis were pleased President
Nicolas Maduro was not invited he is a
dictator and I hope Lacaze can help put
pressure on him about what is happening
in the country but it's domestic issues
like Asia PO is set to focus on first
including crime and the economy wanting
to address insecurity that has become a
major problem here also education and to
generate well-paid jobs that's always a
lawyer and spent many years in Congress
before making it to the presidency Willa
Cather Polk comes from a political
family his great-grandfather was a major
political figure in this country his
father is a former president he made it
to office by creating a coalition of
five center-right parties that gives him
a majority in both chambers of Congress
that's why it won't be difficult for him
to carry out the reforms he wants he's
planning to send an omnibus bill to
address what he says are the country's
biggest problems like the fiscal deficit
unemployment and insecurity mas
importante para he wants to reduce the
deficit by a relevant reduction of
public spending he says he wants to
reduce the deficit without touching
important social policies he may want to
reduce state employees and open up this
country to new markets
LoCascio says he wants to continue the
policies that worked and changed those
that did not
his task will be to maintain the
stability the country has enjoyed for
the past 15 years Teresa Waugh al
jazeera Montevideo